soutenir la libre circulation au sein de
l'union européenne
c'est l'objectif affiché du certificat
sanitaire présenté ce mercredi par la
commission européenne
un projet commun qui pourrait permettre
aux habitants des 27 de voyager
normalement dès cet été
malgré la pandémie un passeport
vaccinale controversé destiné notamment
à aider l'industrie du tourisme en
europe en grande difficulté depuis des
mois
mais claude ce certificat et garantira
que les résultats ou ce qu'ils montrent
les données
l'ensemble des données minimum sont
mutuellement reconnu dans chaque état
membre
testé tout grâce à ce certificat
numérique
nous voulons aider les états membres à
rétablir la liberté de circulation d'une
manière sûre responsable et digne de
confiance
gratuit et non obligatoire ce passeport
vaccinale sera dotée d'un qr code a
présenté sous forme digitale et
indiquera si le porteur est vaccinée si
ce dernier a effectué un test pcr ou
encore s'il est immunisé face au co vie
de 19 pour ceux qui ne disposent pas de
smartphone le format papier pourra
également être présenté un certificat
qui ne s'inscrit pas dans la durée
puisque son utilisation devrait cesser
dès la fin de la pandémie
la commission européenne l'a rappelé la
vaccination ne doit être ni obligatoire
ni discriminatoire
il ne s'agit pas d'une vaccination
obligatoire en europe
il est donc possible pour les gens de
refuser d'être vacciné et il est
également impossible pour certaines
personnes qui veulent être vaccinés de
recevoir le vaccin car ils ne sont pas
prioritaires dans les différentes
stratégies
nous offrons donc une sorte de
possibilité de recevoir sous forme
numérique ou sur papier un véritable
instrument sans aucune discrimination
entre les citoyens
ces deux les personnes non vaccinées
pourront donc continuer de voyager en
europe mais devront éventuellement se
soumettre à des mesures sanitaires tels
que la quarantaine pour les détenteurs
du précieux sésame les quatre vaccins
actuellement autorisées par l' agence
européenne des médicaments seront pris
en compte
pfizer ben tate modern à astrazeneca et
johnson and johnson
mais la commission européenne laisse
toutefois la possibilité pour les états
membres d'accepter les certificats qui
correspondent à d'autres sérum un projet
en forme de challenge pour bruxelles
puisque ce passeport est loin de faire
l'unanimité au sein des vingt-sept